[Musik]
hallo und halleluja ostern was war das
doch
da hat jesus seine poster impfung
gekriegt oder
dann sagt er drei tage flach mit
schweren impfnebenwirkungen
das verschweigt euch der pfarrer immer
jesus ist nach drei tagen wieder
gekommen dass corona virus braucht bis
herbst aber dann ist es auch wieder da
garantiert weil die ampel die
impfpflicht vergeigt hat ja ihr habt
richtig gehört im herbst geht die ganze
scheiße wieder von vorne los
unfassbare blamage für lauterbach ist
das heute wirklich ein ganz persönlicher
achtung kabel freitag
jetzt ist alles egal gestern war ich im
supermarkt da stand ein querdenker ohne
maske vom gemüse hustete auf jeden
einzelnen poco liebe und rief freiheit
freiheit
daneben prügelten sich zwei hausfrauen
um die letzten rollen zweilagige skies
aus papier leute der hamster die
falschen sachen ich habe den keller voll
mit rotwein zigarren und steak
grundnahrungsmittel halt und wenn ich
klopapier brauche 30 seiten aus den
kochbüchern von attila hildmann vegan
packen wenn man schon alle maßnahmen in
die tonne gekloppt warum denn kurz vor
ostern seid ihr bescheuert das war doch
super die letzten zwei jahre kein
verwandtenbesuche kein gottesdienst ich
habe die feiertage im hasenkostüm auf
dem sofa gelegen und mir die eier
und jetzt geht der zirkus wieder los mit
der familie ernsthaft ostern mit den
kindern dem schwiegersohn tante hilde
da hilft nur verreisen zum glück läuft
ja auch der tourismus wieder an und ich
habe eine einfache methode meinen co2
abdruck um die hälfte zu verringern ich
fliege ohne in den urlaub fürs klima ja
wenn jeder nur noch alleine auf die
malediven fliegt die hälfte co2 gespart
wir müssen unabhängig von putins öl und
gas werden und das mit den erneuerbaren
bei uns das kriegen wir ja nicht hin in
sachsen zum beispiel wurden letztes jahr
mehr windräder ab als aufgebaut kein
witz nur ein einziges windrad wurde neu
gebaut eins muss man aber verstehen
viele sachsen sagen nur über all diese
riesen mit dem 32
die kennt doch nur wessis lesen mich war
das wird eh nix mit der energiewende
aber jetzt erholen wir uns erst mal alle
schöne feiertage und vorsicht für viele
kleine kinder ist es das erste ostern
ohne staatliche coruna maßnahmen passt
auf dass die nicht traumatisiert werden
wenn sie den osterhasen das erste mal
ohne maske sehen frohe ostern und
tschüss ihr
seid noch da entspannt euch abonniert
doch den kanal oder guckt euch ein paar
andere videos von uns an ganz wie ihr
möchtet
diese scheiß zigarette schon wieder aus
da wie soll ich mich zu entspannen
das tollste ist auch viel zu heiß ich
schätze wie wow das ist doch echt a